This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a storefront at a major intersection in downtown Toronto, at Spadina and King Street. The space is about 11,000 square feet, and it used to house a massive liquor store, right in the middle of Canada's biggest city. For years, I worked down the street, and let me tell you, that liquor store was bumpin'. That's producer Chris Berube. I remember lines out the door before holidays, and setting aside a whole lunch hour just to get a bottle of wine. But in 2019, the liquor store moved to a new, bigger location close by, and the shop at Spadina and King closed. Since then, all 11,000 square feet have been empty. For a long time, I wondered,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。多伦多市中心有一个主要路口，位于斯帕迪纳街与国王街交汇处，那里有一家店面。
okay, what is going to move in there? I mean, this is a big time space right downtown, but in 2019, it sat empty. 2020, still empty. 2021, empty. 2022, okay, you get the point. But it's only empty for about nine months out of the year because every fall, just like clockwork,
好吧，到底会有什么店搬进来呢？我的意思是，这可是市中心黄金地段的一处大空间，但在2019年，它一直闲置着。
the space has been possessed by a spirit, by spirit Halloween. If you live in the US or Canada, you have probably seen the orange, yellow, and black Spirit Halloween signs. They go up sometime in August in 1500 empty storefronts, and by early November, all of them disappear. Spirit Halloween has become something of an institution. If you aren't familiar, I mean, it's pretty simple.
这个空间被一个“幽灵”占据了——那就是“万圣节幽灵”店（Spirit Halloween）。如果你住在美加两地，你大概见过那些橙、黄、黑三色相间的“万圣节幽灵”招牌。
It's a pop-up store full of Halloween stuff. They sell Halloween masks, Halloween costumes, Halloween costumes for dogs, Halloween decorations, creepy robots, and several different kinds of fake blood. And it's successful. Spirit reportedly sells about a billion dollars worth of merchandise every year. For a long time, I resisted going to Spirit because, I don't know, it just seemed like a lot of loud noises and crowds and children running around. And I gotta say, when I finally took the plunge last fall, it was pretty much that. It's like it's set up to look like a crypt. It's just full of those electric candles that kind of look like fire. After passing through rows of plastic gravestones and being yelled at by a terrifying animatronic clown, I discovered this one blue jumpsuit costume that severely creeped me out.
这是一家摆满万圣节物品的快闪店。他们出售万圣节面具、万圣节服装、狗狗穿的万圣节服装、万圣节装饰品、令人毛骨悚然的机器人，以及好几种不同的假血浆。
So I see an avatar, which honestly is very disturbing. I can't imagine dressing a child like this. I don't like it. Overall, I'd say the experience wasn't really for me. But I know that my opinion is in the minority here, because there are a ton of people who are obsessed with Spirit Halloween. Today is a very special day, my friends, because today is the day that my local Spirit Halloween store has opened and we are here right in front of it about to go in.
所以我看到一个虚拟形象，老实说，这非常让人不安。我无法想象把一个孩子打扮成这样。我可不喜欢。
I'm going to give you a full tour of this year's theme, animatronics. There are countless YouTube videos from creators who treat the first day of the Spirit calendar like a high holy day, walking through the aisles of a freshly opened store and exploring the new products. I love this guy. My name is Jackie and I have a YouTube channel called Super Enthused. Jackie's videos of Spirit Halloween walkthroughs have garnered hundreds of thousands of views. Jackie says the reason Spirit has developed a following is the way they've tried to make the store itself feel like a haunted house. One thing I found, like the first thing that hit me was that Spirit kind of let you play with things. They let you stomp on the floor and activate the
我将带大家完整参观一下今年的主题：电子动画。YouTube上无数的创作者将“万圣节幽灵”日历的第一天视为圣日，他们走过新开业店铺的过道，探索新产品。
animatronics and almost all the others, especially as a younger person, a kid, a teenager. No, no, no, don't touch! Don't touch that! Don't open that! You can't touch anything! You can't play with anything! You're watching you like a hawk if you're going to steal the whole store! But Spirit's like, come in, touch everything, play with all the things!
不，不，不，别碰！别碰那个！别打开那个！你什么都不能碰！你什么都不能玩！如果店里东西被偷了，他们盯着你就像盯着鹰一样！但“万圣节幽灵”却说：进来吧，随便摸，所有东西都可以玩！
Spirit's haunted house energy is a big part of the draw, but there's also an element of scarcity. Because the real hallmark of Spirit Halloween is that it's only open roughly three months out of the year. Spirit Halloween has zero permanent year-round locations, and inside these pop-up stores, there's an overwhelming feeling that everything won't be around for long. Here is what I do not get about Spirit Halloween. The last few years have been considered this kind of retail apocalypse, with lots of brick and mortar
“万圣节幽灵”那种鬼屋般的氛围是吸引人的很大一部分原因，但其中也包含着一种稀缺元素。
chains closing their physical locations. A lot of those retailers have just left empty storefronts across the country. So what does it say about the world of retail, that a seasonal Halloween store is taking all these abandoned spaces for three months a year and making a killing in the process. To understand how Spirit became ubiquitous, I called it the guy who started it. Joe Marver opened Spirit in 1983. And I'll admit, when I met the father of Spirit Halloween, I kind of assumed he'd have a backstory about how he became a Halloween guy.
为了解“万圣节幽灵”是如何变得无处不在的，我打电话给它的创始人。乔·马维尔（Joe Marver）于1983年创立了“万圣节幽灵”。
Like he stumbled into a crypt full of bats or he stumbled upon a pumpkin that was full of bats. But it turns out his childhood was disappointingly bat-free. Did trick or treating out of my house. I mean, we're going back to 1950 is when I was seven years old. My first costume was Zorro.
就像他偶然闯进了一个满是蝙蝠的地下墓穴，或者偶然发现了一个装满蝙蝠的南瓜。但事实证明，他的童年令人失望地没有任何蝙蝠。
Okay, but Joe Marver did tell me as a teen, he attended summer camp at this place with a really spooky name. I went to a camp in Devil's Lake, Wisconsin. In his 20s, Joe Marver moved west to California in search of his fortune. He worked as a clown in Las Vegas, then at a shoe store, and by the early 80s he owned an outlet store in the Bay Area. A haunted outlet store.
好吧，不过乔·马维尔确实告诉我，他十几岁时曾在一个名字非常诡异的地方参加过夏令营。我曾在威斯康星州魔鬼湖的一个营地待过。
It was not haunted. It was just a regular store called Spirit Discount Women's Apparel. But right across the parking lot from Joe's store was a dancewear shop. They sold leotards and tutus, but also a selection of Halloween costumes. And watching their customers gave Joe Marver an idea. They were lined up around the block for the month of October, and it was insane, because our October stunk in the women's apparel business across the street in a strip center. In 1983, the dancewear shop closed,
这里并不是闹鬼。这只是一家普通的店，名叫“幽灵折扣女装”。但在乔的店对面马路停车场，有一家舞蹈服装店。
and Joe Marver decided he could not let those customers go someplace else. So he put the women's clothing in the basement and bought a crop of Halloween costumes. Hmm, I'm gonna go to a trade show. I'm gonna get wigs, makeup, a lot of products that could be for Halloween. That October, Joe completely changed his business for one month only.
乔·马维尔决定不能让那些顾客去别的地方。于是他把女装搬到地下室，并采购了一批万圣节服装。
And Spirit Discount Women's Apparel became Spirit Halloween. Our staff totally was dressing up in costume, something that might have been a costume that we wanted to sell. And it rocked. It was amazing. The new business model worked right away. In his second year, Joe says he made $100,000. Soon, he was running six stores, and then even more. And it's from these early stores that we get the not-built-to-last quality that's
“万圣节幽灵”折扣女装店变成了“万圣节幽灵”店。我们的员工完全盛装打扮成我们想卖的服装造型。而且效果棒极了。太惊艳了。
come to define Spirit Halloween. Now, this predates the rise of pop-up retailers. Back then, there wasn't this modern concept of a cool artisanal clothing shop that's open for two weeks, or a food truck in the parking lot of your favorite bar. Spirit was ahead of all that. And because they were just building for the short term, they used materials that could be put up and taken down really quickly. I remember that the tables for displays
现在，这比快闪零售商的兴起还要早。当时的市场上还没有这种现代概念：开业两周的酷炫手工艺服装店，或是你最喜欢的酒吧停车场里的餐车。
were actually the cardboard boxes that the merchandise came in. Cause he ended up with all these boxes, lots of boxes, you know, maybe a thousand cartons at the time. And you'd pile these boxes up in the middle of the sales floor, drape a black cloth over them. And that was your display table, you know? So ultimate in reduce, reuse, recycle, right?
展示用的桌子其实就是商品运来时装货的纸箱子。因为他最后收集了所有这些箱子，很多的箱子，你知道的，当时可能有一千个纸箱。
That's Mike Olson, who started working with Spirit in the 80s. Mike says while the setup was a little bare bones, Joe Marver had a knack for making his stores feel macabre. You know, the aisles were nice and wide and you were just inundated with all the sights and sounds of Halloween. Joe started experimenting with how much he could scare customers without scaring them away. For example, many spirit stores included baby carriages with creepy dolls in the middle
那是迈克·奥尔森（Mike Olson），他从80年代开始与“万圣节幽灵”合作。迈克说，虽然店铺布置有点简陋，但乔·马维尔很擅长让他的店铺营造出一种阴森恐怖的氛围。
of the action. You had the animatronics, they step on the mat and they scream at you. Customers loved the mix of kitschy and creepy. But early on, Joe hit a major roadblock in expanding the business. Landlords just didn't understand the idea of a temporary store. Mike Olson says they associated the idea with something low rent and unreliable,
你有电子动画道具，他们一踩到垫子上就会尖叫。顾客们非常喜欢这种俗气与诡异结合的风格。
like say a firework stand that would pop up on the side of the road around the 4th of July. Very few landlords wanted to rent their space to a business that was going to put down stakes for eight weeks and then leave that space abandoned. He's calling around to landlords and other brokers and they look at you like you had three heads when you say, look, I've got this temporary Halloween thing.
很少有房东愿意把他们的空间租给一家只停留八周然后就把空间抛弃的商业企业。他四处打电话给房东和其他经纪人，当你说“听着，我有个临时的万圣节项目”时，他们看着你的眼神就像你长了三个脑袋一样。
To find locations, Mike Olsen would drive around town looking for shopping centers with empty rundown storefronts until he found one that might take his call. That was it. When you put it like that, it makes it sound like, well, that was super inefficient, but it was really the only way. Mike Olson says the sales pitch in the early days was pretty difficult. So the Sphere team got creative. Mike remembers trying to win over one corporate landlord with this suite of available spaces.
迈克·奥尔森说，早期的销售说辞相当困难。所以“万圣节幽灵”团队开始发挥创意。
I just know that I wanted to get in and break that nut with him. And eventually called my buddy Anne Sullivan down at the Hayward office. I said, Hey, any chance that we've got a severed arm down in inventory somewhere? And she said, you know, I think we do. So she sends that thing to me and I staple it to a piece of cardboard, put my business card on it and then write on there the gentleman's name, hey, lend me a hand. I need your location here. And I put it in an envelope, sent it off to the guy. And he called me back and I got the deal. Ultimately, Spirit was able to solve their problem largely by paying above market rate
最终，“万圣节幽灵”很大程度上通过为短期租约支付高于市场价的租金，解决了他们的难题。
for their short-term leases. But another thing that helped Spirit was timing. Big box stores spread across America in the 1960s and 70s with the rise of Walmart, Target, and Kmart. By the 1980s, big box retail stores were becoming ubiquitous in the American suburbs. Those retailers put a lot of mom-and and pop and smaller chains out of business. But for Spirit Halloween, the ubiquity of these big boxes was an opportunity. Because if one of these stores closed, which happened from time to time, landlords were
到了20世纪80年代，大卖场零售店在美国家庭郊区变得无处不在。那些零售商让许多夫妻老婆店和小连锁店倒闭了。
stuck. These spaces were purpose-built for something like a Kmart, and they were difficult to repurpose. You couldn't just put in a hospital or an apartment complex into an old big box unless you completely redeveloped the property and got zoning laws changed. Mike Olson says Spirit became a favorite for corporate landlords because of their promise. We'll fill your empty boxes for a couple of months while you look for a new tenant and maybe we'll fix them up a little. We've cleaned more floors, replaced more light bulbs, and fixed more HVAC units across
迈克·奥尔森说，“万圣节幽灵”之所以成为大型房东的最爱，是因为他们做出了承诺。
the country than I would think any other retailer at this point. Because when we go into a space, we need that space to look good. And oftentimes, a retailer, when they leave a space, they're not leaving it in a condition that's ready to occupy. This was Spirit's real estate strategy. Sometimes they'd take an old bank or one time a defunct church, but mostly they were laser focused on abandoned big boxes. Anything over 10,000 square feet,
这就是“万圣节幽灵”的房地产策略。有时他们会租用老旧的银行，或者有一次是一座废弃的教堂，但他们绝大部分精力都高度集中在废弃的大型仓储卖场上。任何超过11,000平方英尺的空间，
preferably across the parking lot from another popular store. If it had good traffic and it was a corner that had across the street a Lowe's or a Home Depot, then that would be enough of a draw. Now we're at a Walmart just off the highway with highway visibility with an exit. Hello, money. By the 90s, Spirit had a few dozen stores. They even managed to secure the perfect celebrity spokesperson. I even had Elvira, Mistress of the Dark, who we put on our billboards with her picture,
如果人流量好，且街角对面有劳氏（Lowe's）或家得宝（Home Depot），那就足够吸引人了。现在我们在高速公路旁的一家沃尔玛，交通便利且靠近出口。
and I got rights to the phone number 1-800-HALLOWEEN. Spirit went national, and pretty soon a big mall brand took notice. Fast forward to 1998, and Spencer Gifts approaches me and says, we would like to talk to you about possibly doing a deal. After 16 years in business, Joe sold Spirit Halloween to Spencer's, a store most Americans will know for their fine array of lava lamps and novelty t-shirts. Joe stayed on as a consultant for a while,
在经营了16年后，乔将“万圣节幽灵”卖给了斯彭斯（Spencer's），这家店大多数美国人对它的印象是出售各种精致的熔岩灯和新奇T恤。
but today, Joe Marver is retired from the company, and he runs a hotel in Washington state. He still dresses up every year for Halloween, and he plays a character for his guests. And I don't do too bad on Elvis voice. People who work for Spirit Halloween talk about a before and an after for the company. Under corporate ownership, Spirit has gone from 65 stores to 1,500, and they moved away from some of the generic costumes they used to carry. Old Spirit would feature largely off-brand costumes. You might've seen jokes about these online,
但今天，乔·马维尔已经从公司退休，他在华盛顿州经营着一家酒店。他每年万圣节仍然会盛装打扮，为他的客人扮演一个角色。我的猫王唱腔学得还算不错。
like the sidekick bros who look suspiciously like Super Mario and Luigi, but today Spirit has the license to real characters from Disney and Marvel and most of the popular horror franchises. Spirit Halloween have corporate owners now and a website where you can buy stuff all year round. But their physical stores are still a temporary operation. Their logo is still plastered on a tarp in front of each storefront.
如今，“万圣节幽灵”有了企业所有者，还有一个全年都可以网购的网站。但他们的实体店仍然是临时运营。他们的 logo 仍然贴在每个店面门前的防水布上。
Their display is still made out of pegboard and they are still only open a few months a year. The biggest thing that stayed the same about Spirit Halloween is their real estate plan. They keep searching for empty big box stores every year. Here's Mike Olson. You know, I'm cruising the newspaper and I see someone file for bankruptcy. Admittedly, I'm immediately jumping on the, you know, say, okay, where are the stores, how big are they, and can I get, can I take advantage of this? Hey, I'm immediately jumping on the, you know, say, okay, where are the stores? How big are they? And can I get to kind of take advantage of this? Hey, I'm a broker. I can admit that. I'll go with that.
迈克·奥尔森说：你知道的，我在浏览报纸时看到有人申请破产。我得承认，我马上就会跳出来，说，好吧，店在哪里，它们有多大，我能不能利用这个机会？
You know, it's it's finding opportunities for my client. Spirit has benefited whenever there has been a crisis in the retail sector, first with the wave of corporate closures in the 90s. Good guys in CompUSA and Circuit City and Best Buy was out there, Barnes & Noble, Borders Books, all of the big box, you know, the category killers. Then, there was a much bigger crisis in the American economy. Get to 2008 financial meltdown, 2009, I think the Phoenix metro area at one time had 256 empty retail boxes, big boxes. Take your pick.
接着，美国经济迎来了更大的危机。到了2008年的金融崩盘，2009年，我记得菲尼克斯都会区一度有256个空置的零售大卖场。任君挑选。
Many brands didn't survive the financial downturn or lost out to Amazon or other online retailers. And Spirit has taken many of their old storefronts. Yeah, we could take old Sears boxes, old Kmart boxes. You've probably seen those, you know, the 40,000 square foot Toys R Us box or the 30,000 square foot Bed Bath and Beyond. This kind of guerrilla adaptive reuse
这种游击式的适应性再利用，让一些批评者称“万圣节幽灵”为美国零售业的死神。事实上，整件事在网络上变成了一个笑话。
has led some critics to call Spirit the Grim Reaper of American retail. In fact, the whole thing has become a joke online. Yeah, we're part of the meme universe. You probably see the memes out there that whenever the government shuts down, for example, someone hangs the Spirit Halloween banner, superimposes on the White House.
作为一家企业，“万圣节幽灵”发展得很好。但我想知道城市政策专家对此有何看法。雷切尔·奎德诺（Rachel Quednow）是“坚固城镇”（Strong Towns）组织的节目总监，该组织倡导反对郊区式的规划。她并不喜欢“万圣节幽灵”所代表的一切。
As a business, Spirit is doing well for itself. But I wanted to know what urban policy folks think about it. Rachel Quednow is the program director at Strong Towns, an organization that advocates against suburban-style planning. And she doesn't like what spirit represents. If our cities are thinking about like, what is a long-term benefit for us financially, for our residents, then we shouldn't be thinking
商业房地产数据公司CoStar在2023年发布的一份报告显示，美国人均零售空间超过50平方英尺。
about pursuing, you know, really short-term, massive businesses like this. A 2023 report from the commercial real estate data company CoStar says the United States has more than 50 square feet of retail space per person. A 2023 report from the commercial real estate data company CoStar says the United States has more than 50 square feet of retail space per person. That's much higher than countries like Australia, which have about 11 square feet. European countries have even less. And in Rachel's opinion, the success of Spirit is something that only happens because we
老实说，对于现在所有闲置的大型卖场，我认为最好的情况是把它们推倒，让它们回归土地，特别是当它们位于城镇边缘、没有车就很难到达的地方时。
have a bunch of big companies that build big boxes and then leave them empty. Honestly, for all the huge big box stores that are now sitting vacant, I think the best case scenario is to knock them down, let them return to the earth, particularly if they're on the edge of town where it's hard to access without a car. I don't think that's a viable model to hope that we could transform all these stores into something new, especially when there's more and more becoming vacant every day. For his part, Mike Olson doesn't agree that there's some big overabundance of retail space.
就他而言，迈克·奥尔森不同意零售空间存在巨大过剩的说法。
In fact, he says right now, it's kind of a low point in the market for Spirit. We're in a completely different era. We're at a point where it's difficult to find spaces because there hasn't been much in the way of new construction for retail across the country. And what retail is out there happens to be mixed use, you know, retail on the main floor, apartments or office above. If Mike's right, Spirit still manages to find hundreds of empty storefronts every year. The days of Spirit's real estate team driving around and begging landlords for space, those are over.
如果迈克是对的，“万圣节幽灵”每年依然能找到数百个空置店面。“万圣节幽灵”的房地产团队开车到处求房东给个铺位的日子已经一去不复返了。
Today, larger corporate landlords expect Spirit's calls every year. And those calls start as early as January. That's because Spirit is just a regular part of their business now. Look, we are no different than any other retailer out there right now, because they're doing the exact same thing.
如今，较大的企业房东每年都在期待“万圣节幽灵”的电话。而这些电话早在1月就开始打了。
I guarantee you, it's just on a slower scale. Every retailer is a temporary tenant. It just depends on how long they're temporary. Sears was temporary for 130 years. Other tenants, well, they're temporary for two years. You know? But that's the reality of retail. Ultimately, Spirit isn't the reason
听着，我们现在和其他任何零售商没什么不同，因为他们在做完全相同的事情。
for empty big box stores. There are bigger factors at play here. I don't think that there's something inherently wrong with Spirit. It's more like a symptom of a bigger problem. Most of our cities today, unfortunately, are really structured to invite those large scale developments. Our zoning codes, our rules around parking requirements,
我不认为“万圣节幽灵”本身有什么不对。它更像是一个更大问题的症状。
our tax structures are set up so that when the Walmart at the Target or the big supermarket wants to come to town, we bend over backwards. I think it's easy to find some gruesome metaphor for spirit. To say it's like a vulture or a zombie or a grim reaper. But actually, I think spirit is more like a hermit crab. It finds these different shells, and it discards them as it goes along. Sometimes the shell is an old bank, or a giant big box, or an abandoned liquor store.
我想很容易为“万圣节幽灵”找到一些可怕的比喻。说它像秃鹰、僵尸或死神。但实际上，我认为“万圣节幽灵”更像寄居蟹。它寻找不同的贝壳，边走边丢弃它们。
It just uses these spaces because they're there. As to why Spirit is popular, I mean, there's no mystery here. Halloween is fun. It's the only holiday where you get to buy a present for yourself. And it's the only night of the year where it's socially acceptable to dress up and just be whoever you want. Oh my gosh, okay, maybe I have to get this. This is a costume.
至于为什么“万圣节幽灵”如此受欢迎，我的意思是，这没有什么神秘的。万圣节很有趣。这是唯一一个你可以给自己买礼物的节日。
And the costume is guy who works at Spirit Halloween, so it says Spirit Crew Workshirt. There's a patch that says Spirit and Skeleton Crew on the side. Ooh, that's awful tempting. Alright all you ghouls and goblins, do not touch that dial. More with Chris Berube after this. So we're back with Chris Borube. Hey Chris. Hey Roman. So you have a little bit more to this story? I do.
这个服装是“万圣节幽灵”员工，所以上面写着“幽灵团队工作衬衫”。侧面有一个写着“幽灵”和“骷髅团队”的徽章。哦，太诱人了。
I mean, I feel like in talking about the last few years of Halloween, there've been a couple of trends in America. Of course, there's been, you know, the ubiquity and the spread of Spirit Halloween and other stores, you know, there's also Spooker Superstore, Halloween Express, all these other ones. But there's also been another consumer product that has been just everywhere the last couple of Halloweens. So it's been meme to death.
我的意思是，我觉得在谈论过去几年的万圣节时，美国出现了一些趋势。当然，你知道的，有“万圣节幽灵”和其他商店的无处不在和普及，你知道的，还有“惊悚超级商店”（Spooker Superstore）、“万圣节快车”（Halloween Express）以及所有这些其他的店。
It's become this kind of obsession for people around Halloween in this country. Roman, are you familiar with the giant skeleton? So I've seen these around. So how actually tall are these? These are about 12 feet tall. So if you don't live in the US, maybe you haven't seen these,
罗曼，你对巨型骷髅熟悉吗？所以我见过这些。那么这些到底有多高呢？它们大约有12英尺高。
but if you're in America, they're kind of unavoidable around Halloween now. So in 2020, first Halloween of the pandemic, everybody was wondering, you know, we're under lockdown. It's like, are we going to do Halloween this year? And that's the year Home Depot decided, we're gonna roll out this new product. It is a 12 foot plastic skeleton
因此，在2020年——大流行的第一个万圣节，每个人都在想，你知道的，我们在封锁中。就像是，我们今年还要过万圣节吗？
you can put in your yard with light up eyes. It costs about $300. And a lot of people, including me, were wondering like, given the price, given the size, would anybody buy these? And they sold out immediately. Like they were just gone, unavailable these? And they sold out immediately. Like they were just gone, unavailable. 2021, they sold out again.
售价约为300美元。许多人，包括我在内，都在想——考虑到价格和尺寸，会有人买这些吗？它们立刻就卖光了。就像它们一下子没了，买不到了。
There's like articles in newspapers that are like, when's the skeleton coming back? Where do you buy the skeleton? And it's hilarious cause like, this is all from a company that is not known for like Halloween stuff. Like Home Depot, I mostly associate with buying lumber. Yeah, I mostly associate with getting frustrated
报纸上甚至有这样的文章：“骷髅什么时候回来？”“你在哪里买的骷髅？”这太滑稽了，因为这居然出自一家并不以万圣节商品闻名的公司。
and not knowing where to go to find a thing. Yes, Home Depot is Byzantine, yeah. But like this thing has been such a success, like, you know, it's probably one of the more famous things about Home Depot right now. Yeah, it's wild. I mean, the skeleton, it feels like it has become just like a part of Halloween now.
是的，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，这个骷髅，感觉它现在已经成为万圣节的一部分了。
And I've seen them all over the place. Like I've seen them outside of chiropractor's offices, which ha, ha, ha, very funny, it's a skeleton. There was one in Midtown Manhattan, for no apparent reason, that I kept running into. But I've always had a lot of questions about these. Like I've always wondered, is it kind of a nightmare to own one of these skeletons?
但我一直对这些有很多疑问。比如我一直想知道，拥有这样一个骷髅是不是一场噩梦？
You mean like for the other, you know, 11 months of the year, like where do you store them? How do you upkeep them? That kind of thing. Exactly, and personally, I would be most worried about judgment, I feel like. Like what would neighbors think if you had this giant skeleton in your yard?
你是说就像在一年中剩下的那11个月里，你把它们存放在哪里？你如何保养它们？诸如此类的问题。
Like is it allowed also to have something this big just on your property? So I was wondering, what is it actually like to own a giant skeleton? So I called up a friend of mine. My name is Bobby, and I am a proud owner of the 12 foot Home Depot skeleton. Bobby Lord, you may know him from the world of podcasting. He used to work on Heavyweight,
所以我打电话给我的一个朋友。我叫鲍比（Bobby），我是12英尺高家得宝骷髅的自豪拥有者。
and he does the music in the mixing for Science Versus, a show that we love over here at 99PI. Yeah, I absolutely adore both those shows. at 99PI. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I absolutely adore both those shows. So Bobby, you know, Bobby likes Halloween. His wife, Deidre, she loves Halloween. And when they heard about the skeleton first, they were interested, but they were initially kind of hesitant.
他曾在《重量级》（Heavyweight）节目工作，他为我们99PI非常喜欢的节目《科学 vs》（Science Versus）制作音乐和混音。
It's prohibitively expensive, unless you're insane, about Halloween decorations. And we were very blessed to have a bunch of awesome, funny friends who pitched in as a wedding gift for us, got it for us as a wedding gift. I was among those friends. It was... Yes, I didn't know if you wanted me to break the...
这价格高得离谱，除非你对万圣节装饰痴迷到疯狂的地步。我们非常幸运，有一群超级棒、很有趣的朋友，他们凑钱作为结婚礼物送给了我们。我就是那些朋友之一。这……
No, it's okay. It is okay to say this. So not only is Bobby your friend, you're involved in this story. You're the reason why this story is happening right now. I don't think it's good journalism, necessarily, but... Yeah, despite my misgivings, I and a group of like 10 people went in together and bought them this gigantic home-to-go skeleton for their wedding. When you guys bought the skeleton for us,
是的，尽管我有疑虑，我和大约10个人一起凑钱给他们买了这个巨大的家得宝骷髅作为婚礼礼物。当你们给我们买这个骷髅时，
he arrived in the most hilarious box I've ever seen in my life on our front porch. It was so hard to just even open the box, move the box, get the stuff out of the box, and then I had to break down the box. And it was like, when you're breaking down this massive cardboard box, it was like, you know, cardboard is like pretty, pretty strong material, especially when it's that big. This is becoming like a white elephant for him. Like, I'm getting a little nervous for Bobby at this point. Yeah, I was, I gotta be honest.
这就像是为他准备的一件白色大象礼物（注：指昂贵而无用或难以处理的礼物）。在这个时候，我开始为鲍比感到有点紧张了。
Like as soon as we pulled the trigger on this, I was like, what a great idea. They're gonna think this is so funny. And then I became anxious like right away. Like, am I signing up these people I care about for just a terrible experience? Totally. When you start like putting it all together
就像我们刚决定买下它时，我就想：这主意太棒了。他们会觉得这太有趣了。然后我马上就开始焦虑起来。
and putting all the pieces together, in your head are you like, oh no, we've made a terrible mistake? Or was it like, this is amazing, this is changing my life for the better? Funny that you say that, because I do think at one point it occurred to me that it might be a mistake. Like the type of thing that you think is so funny and then you're actually doing it and you're like, oh my God, this is so big. It really is so big.
你有没有觉得，当你开始把所有这些零件组装在一起时，你在脑海里会想：哦不，我们犯了个大错误？
And then we had just moved into this house like two months prior into a new neighborhood. So I think part of you is thinking like, God, is everyone going to hate us or be annoyed by us? So they put it up. They named the skeleton, Tommy Lee Bones. So he's up there now, but they've got these worries. Thankfully, it seems like people in the neighborhood are pretty into the skeleton. Nobody has complained so far.
因此他们把它竖了起来。他们给这个骷髅起名叫汤米·李·博恩斯（Tommy Lee Bones）。所以他现在就立在那儿，但他们心里还是有些担忧。
And they've had the skeleton up in their yard now pretty consistently for about two years, partly because there is nowhere reasonably to store a 12-foot skeleton in the off time. So for Bobby and Deidre, so far, they've been putting the skeleton in the backyard in the off season, and they've been putting the skeleton in the backyard in the off season and they've been putting different seasonal clothing on him depending on the time of year.
因此，对鲍比和迪德丽（Deidre）来说，到目前为止，他们在淡季时把骷髅放在后院，并且根据一年中的不同时间给他换上不同的季节性服装。
So he's had a Hawaiian shirt and shorts for the summer, you know, things like that. We also put a big Santa hat on him for Christmas last year, which by the way, they don't make a Santa hat big enough for the 12 foot skeleton. So my wife bought four Santa hats and we kind of cut it and constructed one super large Santa hat. And then it was a big to do to like get up there and tape it to his head and stuff. So for the most part, they love the skeleton. It's been a great experience,
所以夏天他穿过夏威夷衫和短裤，诸如此类。去年圣诞节我们还给他戴了一顶巨大的圣诞老人帽，顺便说一句，他们并没有生产大到适合12英尺骷髅戴的圣诞老人帽。
but he does admit there have been a few drawbacks. Like other than being committed to large-scale crafts, like, what are some of the drawbacks here? Well, okay, the maintenance issues, you know, predictable. You've got to do some upkeep. You have to replace parts once in a while. Uh, Bobby says it has scared some children. He has a cousin or a nephew who's been a little bit unnerved by it. But actually, it's funny,
呃，鲍比说这吓到了一些小孩子。他有一个表弟或侄子被它吓得有点不安。但实际上，这很有趣，
because the most disappointing thing about the skeleton, it's not, like, the negative reactions from people. It's not the stuff I was worried about. According to Bobby, it's actually how little people have reacted to it. I naively thought like, oh my God, we're gonna be like basically a tourist attraction in the neighborhood.
根据鲍比的说法，关于这个骷髅最让人失望的事情，其实不是人们的负面反应。
We're gonna be, we'll have like a Google map. People will be coming from miles around to see the big skeleton. That same Halloween I saw, like within one square mile of us, like literally like 12 people have the skeleton. And then also they're all doing it better than us. Like they have more decorations around him and like cool costumes on him and stuff.
万圣节那天，我看到在我们方圆一平方英里内，简直有大约12个人也拥有这个骷髅。而且他们做出来的效果比我们更好。
So no, a lot of people have the big skeleton and it was not as, we weren't as unique as I thought it might be. So the problem is that this wasn't weird enough. 12 foot skeleton has become too mainstream. It's too popular. Exactly, and then there's this like arms race to have the best decorated skeleton.
12英尺高的骷髅已经变得太主流了。它太受欢迎了。
So, Roman, is this not in some ways the most human tragedy that we search for novelty, we push for greater achievement, and then we normalize even these, you know, most remarkable of human accomplishments? The most remarkable human achievements. I mean, I don't know if I'd put 12-foot skeleton in that, but, you know. I think there are many people who have bought the skeleton who might disagree with you. Thanks, Roman.
罗曼，这在某种程度上难道不是最典型的人类悲剧吗——我们追逐新鲜感，追求更大的成就，然后却将这些甚至是最了不起的人类成就也变得平庸化？
Thank you Chris. 99% Invisible was produced this week by the cadaverous Chris Berube and Jaka Merdonado Medina edited by Skellington Prime. Mix and editing by Mar Scream Gonzalez. Music by Swannn Rial Monsters. Fact checking by Skara Bullens. Our executive producer is Cathy Boo. Our senior editor is Delaney Halloween. Our digital director is Kurt Goulstad. Our intern is Taylor Shredrick. The rest of the screen includes Freddie vs. Jason DeLeon, Emmett FitzPeryl, Stabriela Gladney, Christopher Here's Johnson, Lasha Madonna the Dead, Vivian Slay, Joe Murder of Crosenberg, Nina Ptokula, and me, Roman Mars Attacks.
谢谢克里斯。《99%隐形》本周由面容枯槁的克里斯·贝鲁比（Chris Berube）制作，雅卡·梅尔多纳多·梅迪纳（Jaka Merdonado Medina）由斯克林顿·普赖姆（Skellington Prime）剪辑。混音和剪辑由玛尔·斯克里姆·冈萨雷斯（Mar Scream Gonzalez）完成。音乐由斯万恩·里阿尔·蒙斯特（Swannn Rial Monsters）创作。事实核查由斯卡拉·布伦斯（Skara Bullens）负责。我们的执行制作人是凯西·布（Cathy Boo）。我们的资深编辑是德兰妮·万圣节（Delaney Halloween）。我们的数字总监是库尔特·古尔斯塔德（Kurt Goulstad）。我们的实习生是泰勒·施雷德里克（Taylor Shredrick）。其余工作人员包括弗雷迪大战杰森·德莱昂（Freddie vs. Jason DeLeon）、埃米特·菲茨佩里尔（Emmett FitzPeryl）、斯塔布里埃拉·格拉德尼（Stabriela Gladney）、克里斯托弗·这是约翰逊（Christopher Here's Johnson）、死者拉沙·麦当娜（Lasha Madonna the Dead）、薇薇安·斯莱（Vivian Slay）、克罗森伯格的乔·谋杀（Joe Murder of Crosenberg）、妮娜·普托库拉（Nina Ptokula），还有我，罗曼·马斯袭击记（Roman Mars Attacks）。
The 90% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Katie Klein, Ben Frisch, and Katie Thomas. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And spooky, scary, Oakland, California. You can find us all on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server, where the cadaverous Chris Berube will be posting extra material from this week's episode. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI, at 99PI.org. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《90%隐形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本周要特别感谢凯蒂·克莱因（Katie Klein）、本·弗里施（Ben Frisch）和凯蒂·托马斯（Katie Thomas）。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客大家庭的一部分，现总部位于潘多拉大厦向北六个街区。这里是令人毛骨悚然、恐怖的加利福尼亚州奥克兰。你可以在所有常用的社交媒体网站上找到我们，还有我们的新Discord服务器，面容枯槁的克里斯·贝鲁比将在那里发布本周节目的额外素材。获取该链接以及《99PI》每一期往期节目的方式，请访问99PI.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。